I know Nick is tired he's been up all
night memorizing his kids names
Nick Cannon finds himself at the center
of dad jokes during the mass singers
comedy roast night roasting all night
all night we roasted all night we
roasted yep the judges of the singing
competition couldn't help but poke fun
at Nick who just welcomed his 11th child
earlier this month with Abby De la Rosa
kids you know I got a lot of them so
naturally judge and comedian Ken Jong
threw a little shade at the host I know
Nick is tired he's been up all night
memorizing his kids names
but the roasting didn't stop there
contestant snowstorm also chimed in with
a jab so this song goes out to my
favorite fearless lady Nicole who has
had more famous exes than Nick has had
baby mamas
[Music]
the baby mamas I was always like yo I
want a big family too so you know the
Lord has blessed me with what I asked
ask and you shall receive I'm sorry I'm
just so scared to get too close to you I
don't want to get pregnant so I'm gonna
oh she's funny
it's pretty cold maybe I do
Nick's got quite the growing family tree
so let's quickly break it down he's got
three kids with Abby newborn beautiful
and one-year-old twins Zion and cilian
too he's also Father to 11 year old
twins Moroccan and Moreau with Mariah
Carey five-year-old golden one-year-old
powerful and one month old rise with
Brittany Bell four-month-old legendary
with Bree tazy I'm a whole human I'm
responsible for it and two-month-old
Onyx he shares with lenisha Cole the
stork is on the way we'll see how it
trickles down and y'all the cannon
crew's about to get even bigger because
Nick's got another kid on the way with
Alyssa Scott following the tragic death
of their five-month-old son Zen last
December who battled a brain tumor I
lost my youngest son
people keep talking to me about grieving
and allowing it to happen and why are
you at work but that's all I know and
while the internet's got lots to say
about Nick's big family the 42 year old
TV personality explains why his
untraditional lifestyle Works luckily
we're in a world where my life and I
think I might have said this and was
misquoted before but I was like I get
I'm blessed with the opportunity I get
to spend more time with my children
every single day because of my world and
my business my life and splitting time
between all the kids isn't as hard as it
seems it's not as difficult as people
think it would be but I understand
because it's a very unorthodox scenario
but it actually I mean I dedicate
probably my entire day to my children as
for the ladies well source told ET in
August they all get along quote the
mothers of Nick Cannon's children are
cordial and respectful to each other for
the most part it's a topic Brie opened
up to ET about just days before
legendary's home birth we just get along
so well and everything just flows and
when you have honesty and all those
things it kind of makes it easy
foreign